welcome to the recruitment mentors
podcast my name
is hisham azuz today i'm really excited
to be joined by jeanette harvey who is
the founder and ceo
of harper and gray harper and gray is a
recent recruitment business that
jeanette has launched
and their mission as a company is to
partner with companies
on their journey to create more diverse
equitable and inclusive organizations
before that jeanette launched her own
business and before she launched her own
business she worked for the s3 group for
over
a decade initially starting with her
huxley banking brand which she built
from the ground up
and with her latias being spent on their
real staffing brand
which is one of the biggest life science
recruitment brands globally
jeanette consistently led the brand to
double-digit growth and along the way
has been recognized as
one of the top hundred influential
staffing leaders in
north america by sia jeanette thank you
for joining me on the podcast
thanks for having me i've been really
looking forward to this one
and uh what we always like to start is
in your opinion
what characteristics and traits do you
think make up a highly successful
recruitment consultant
yeah so no substitute for work ethic i'm
sure that probably comes up a lot
but recruitment is hard work and there's
there's no
there's no getting around that but i
think really
a willingness and desire to
connect with people on a human level
so that um ability to build rapport
and to actually be interested in people
to um do what you say you're gonna do
i think there's a big piece around um
personal brand that that kind of
that that goes right alongside that
and so so being sort of fiercely
protective
of the service that you are going to be
offering both your
clients and and candidates because
that's
that's the collateral that you take with
you as you build your career
um really interesting so i'm really
excited to
sort of unpack your journey i've been
seeing a lot of things that you've been
sharing
over the last sort of six or so months
and
so just for people listening for for
context you really built your
recruitment career
which you spent over 10 years at the s3
group
right um as you were sharing with me
before
and spent a year in the uk but never on
uk markets you've always been
focused on the american markets and then
in 2005
you actually took your career to the
states and co-founded
um the s3 group over there and then
whilst your time there you ended up
obviously managing and leading multiple
brands
so i'm really excited to unpack that and
i guess where
i always like to start because there's
always a story or two there but like
how how would you describe your first
gem recruitment
what was that like yeah so i i've been
with the s3 group
for 15 years and i
i joined there in in 2005 and so
it was quite interesting that first year
in recruitment because
it was based thousands of miles away
from my
uh client base i i built
the us banking business from london
and so that was some pretty anti-social
hours as you can
imagine and a few sacrifices that came
alongside that
but it was really really exciting
because back in 2005
there really weren't any uk recruitment
companies to speak of that were in the
us i mean
s3 really cracked that that market
and um so it was it was
exciting to have a blank slate
and really have
you know the okay it was the states it
felt like the world was
was our oyster at the time and um
yeah there's something to be said for um
you know building
a reputation and a and a brand
organically so although
we have made a lot of traction with
with some big players in the uk that
didn't necessarily translate to
doing business with them stateside so
it was really a lot of business
development building
out a really solid candidate niche
um and and and really uh
really really putting in the the work
um kind of long term to
to to sort of uh build and establish the
business
so on so you mention it a bit there but
whenever we have sort of um recruitment
professionals from
the s3 brand on here i'm just always
interested to hear people's
opinions or the way that they would
describe the business because there's so
many stories
of the s3 group and what sort of was
achieved within that business like when
you was
before you obviously moved to the the us
like what what did that business sort of
feel like like what was the culture like
how would you describe the culture when
you was working there in
in the uk out of interest yeah and the
culture of
s3 has without a shadow of a doubt
really evolved
uh back in 2005 i would say
the word that comes to mind is pretty
hardcore
you know it was high high levels of
discipline
and it was you know very it was
it was kind of long hours and
you know it was a kpi driven business
i'll be honest with you for me i'm
extremely
uh kind of self-disciplined anyway and
you know any standards that were sort of
imposed it
on me i i've always exceeded that anyway
so it wasn't really it wasn't an issue
and i quite like the idea of
a simple blueprint so coming into the
business and kind of knowing
if you do the following activities right
who are high standard
you'll be successful that there's
there's something quite reassuring in
that
and so i really worked in a very
candidate driven way
and uh yeah it was it was amazing i mean
for me within
my first my first nine months
i uh i hit s3 top rookie
and on a private jet to the opening game
of the world cup so
that really that set the scene for my
uh career with s3 and uh
it became very difficult to top that
let's say yeah i can imagine
so so do you mention that i'm just i'm
just curious
jeanette you mentioned that you're
someone that hold yourself to
quite high standards anyway where
where's that come from
out of interest have you always been
that way or how
come oh yeah i am i've always been that
way
i grew up with very little and so i
think when you
grow up with very little that definitely
impacts your mindset
and i've had to work extremely hard for
everything that i've had
and but i i never took for granted
the option or the the ability to be able
to do that i was
grateful for the opportunity and i made
the most of it
yeah okay so a couple of things and then
we'll
sort of segue into you actually going
over to this date so
i would say i think a lot more of it is
happening now but before covid i would
say
most aggressive or progressive
uh recruitment businesses would have had
sort of us
on on their business plan in terms of
diversifying
their client base and these types of
things and
so i guess i just wanted to ask you
there'll be people listening to this
that may be early on in their journey
in building out a u.s market for their
business etc so
just curious to hear from you like what
were some of the things that
i guess you had to maybe learn quite
quickly the hard way that you had to
sort of adapt to the nuances of
dealing with the us market i don't know
does anything come up there that
sort of sticks in mind where if you had
someone new
join in your team or one of your teams
where you'd say this is sort of how
the us do business here i guess you've
already done it to be fair so you
haven't got much to compare to the uk
but i don't know i guess what comes up
for you that
may be slightly different that some of
us that have always served the uk market
or europe markets may not understand or
would have to learn the hard way
yeah i think going into the uk market
going into the u.s market from the uk
market
there's obviously such a vast difference
in the size of the markets
it's huge and you can get
really uh that that could could almost
be quite overwhelming and where i've
seen other people
come and uh and try to replicate what we
did
and not be successful often it's been a
lack of focus
so it has been you know trying to go out
too much
um and uh and really kind of feeling the
effects of the overwhelm
of exactly how big that market is i
think it's important to go
in on on a tight niche
and to to really understand what your
proposition
is and uh you know to
to sort of build a build a brand build a
candidate community
um and um and and really
expand and grow through that and
sometimes it can feel quite counter
intuitive to
go quite narrow but i think in this
instance
is it's it's a really smart way to
approach it
sure so just on this because i'm sure
you've done
a lot of this as you're growing the
brands and the teams but would just be
interested to get your take on this
obviously
you'll be aware that i'd i'd like to
think that a lot of
recruitment companies have this idea of
sort of inch-wide mild deep and niche
right so i guess
like from your perspective and your lens
like what how niche is
niche enough if you get what i mean like
when you say you have to have a real
focusing niche like how
for people listening like what does that
actually mean is it am i just doing
one job title one seniority
in one sector or i don't know how do you
sort of communicate and feel about
what is is niche enough yeah you need to
obviously it's
it depends entirely on the sector um
and uh and and really the domain that
you're looking at
so you you need to to
be able to take stock of how what the
candidate demand looks like in in that
marketplace but obviously start you know
there's smaller that you can
you can start it it's easier to kind of
expand the parameters than to to kind of
go the
the opposite direction but i think that
you really at minimum looking at a
specific
practice area right so if you're doing
life sciences for example you're
probably going to want to pick farmer
or medical device for example
and then quality or regulatory within
that and that that's gotta at least
be that's that's gonna be the your
minimum level
of kind of niching down and you may well
target specific job titles yeah
okay that's that's good to know quite
practical but i know that will help a
lot of people
listen to this so final question i guess
on sort of early days
i'm always interested to hear sort of
answer to this it seems like you had a
real positive start but
if you were able to go back to
um 2005 and give jeanette any advice
what would you say to her out of
interest
to enjoy the uh enjoy the time
that it you are an individual con a
contributor
um you know it was uh it was
probably one of the most enjoyable
times of my career i love leadership and
i spent a long time in leadership
and but there's something to be said for
being able to see
that direct correlation between um
you know i can change the outcome of
my business through what i do today
right so that actual gratification um
is uh is is is quite is quite immediate
and so yeah i think i think enjoying
that
um while while i could that's that's
probably what i'd go back and tell
myself yeah
really interesting so so just just to
paint a picture for everyone then so
obviously i guess the first thing that
i'd be interested because obviously you
took your
recruitment career to the states in 2005
right um so not long after you joined
the s3 group in 2004. so i guess my
first
question really obviously you mentioned
there the high standards and with that
would have been
sort of internal competition like why it
seemed like again you go off to a really
great start
rook of the year within nine months
etcetera but like
why was jeanette able to get that
opportunity to
take the s3 group to north america and
and start
that like why was you trusted with that
opportunity i have interest why are you
and not the person sitting next to you
well number one that's what i was hired
to do
but um you know i mean realistically i'm
i'm sure the company wouldn't have
invested in
actually taking me and getting me a visa
i hadn't come in and and shown
um what i would be capable of of doing
on on the market
i think recruitment there's no way of
getting around this
it's a performance environment and
you know it's not
that there's there's no hiding from
performance and
that in the early point certainly from
leadership perspective
i definitely look at attitudes and
inputs
and just ability to to kind of push
yourself
and and get outside your comfort zone
and to make the difficult phone calls
and things like that
and i think it was it was probably the
same for
for my leaders when when i was uh you
know first in the business
i was not afraid to make the difficult
calls i wasn't afraid to push myself out
of my comfort zone
i was always willing to learn i had a
good attitude
and those things alongside performance
are you know really what you would look
for
when starting out a new venture a new a
new business
yeah no i love that and so just
just so we will understand them for
those listening so when you so where did
you then base yourself
when you went to america i was in new
york okay so you went to new york cool
so just could you just would you mind
just painting a picture of the actual
the business that you were starting like
how many of you went over was it just
yourself like what
did the actual business look like that
you were starting in new york at that
stage
yeah so the business the business in new
york there were five of us
that moved over in in this sort of
initial
team and um
my responsibility was to build out the
bank and technology business
and you know that was
that was that was interesting we were
kind of a perm only business
for really the first couple of years
that we were out there
and i built a
a really high value a really high value
business
effectively so um
we spent a lot of time really deciding
and picking
um quite thoughtful niches
that would not only generate
um sustainable revenue for us but would
also open up the doors to the broader
client as well
so i think there's a huge benefit to
picking um you know the the sort of
verticals where
the client really really needs your help
right is not only
uh can does that mean you can command
uh quite high fees but it also means
that
the client you know has a different
level of respect for you
if you're able to deliver in um
in a vertical that is is so difficult
that means that it's quite easy to get
access to
to kind of the broader jobs and to to
kind of penetrate the clients from there
and and so that's kind of exactly what
we did
and within uh 12 to 18 months
the team in in new york the banking
technology team
it became the most profitable perm team
globally in s3 and it sort of
continued on that track for the
remainder of the
the years that i kind of led it so it
just really went from strength to
strength
so so on that a real popular a really
popular sort of
area that a lot of recruiters message me
that i'm sure you found this in your
career when leading teams and
things but a lot of recruiters messaged
me always asking for
me to ask people like yourself for
advice practical
tips on on the client side so
i guess the the question i have for you
to sort of try and
encourage you to share some of the
things that you've learned in your
career is
during that period then it seemed like
you were really strategic
which is i think a lot of people
probably even missed that part
um but like what was what ended up being
like your most effective way to
win business and and build these
relationships that then meant that
this was the ended up being the most
profitable part of the
s3 group globally like what i don't know
what comes up for you
what really works with that it's a
two-step thing it's it's going
in with something that is really
valuable for the client
so what a lot of the mistakes a lot of
people make
is their outreach is literally knocking
on the door
and saying hi i'm i'm you know mr
recruiter
uh you know do you have any jobs you
know and
it's nothing more you know it's not more
sophisticated than that
and the the reality is that there's you
and another 100 recruitment companies
that are doing that
and so for me the outreach to
clients is never about me
it's never about will you work with me
it's always a
leading with the value that i can
provide to
a client and so if you the benefit of
really niching down is from an industry
perspective you understand the trends
you understand where there
is where it's candidates short and when
it's candidates short then you can
take your candidate to market and feel
confident
that you're that the client is actually
going to be interested
in what you have to say because you're
going to solve a problem for them
and so taking that approach is is really
the way to
open the door with a client and then
when you open the door with the client
you stand and fall on your service right
so you need to make sure that you
um you know you you do what you say
you're gonna do
so not only you kind of delivering on
that particular
search on on that that particular job
and and you know possibly the candidate
that they were originally interested in
but that's how you then develop the
relationship
across other verticals and and then it
becomes much more
um you know lead sales through service
yeah no i really like the way that you
put that so
so as as you shared of us that became
really profitable part of the the
business globally
so then when by that point was you then
more on a
sort of in the leadership capacity than
you were a contributor capacity or
just um help me out on that sort of
journey when did you then start getting
involved with
leading other brands like when did this
real leadership
piece come into it yeah so probably for
the first three years with the company i
did a hybrid role so
um individual contributor and and then
sort of individual contributor and
manager a lot of people find that quite
a difficult job
and to focus on their own production
and tr higher training
i personally found it to be one of the
easier leadership gigs because
i think people really underestimate the
power
of role modeling of being able to
just show people how to do the job
it's actually easier than telling people
how to do the job
so i i i quite enjoyed that and but then
after about
three years we're really in high growth
mode i mean to give you an idea
we started out as i said the kind of the
five of us
that ended up being kind of two of us
and that that kind of stayed with the
business long term
and so take what we grew that business
from
you know no people to 500 people by the
time that i left
and so that was uh you know just a ton
of
a ton of growth during that time um
yeah so okay that really paints a
picture thank you so i guess
there's a couple of things that there'll
be a lot of people that listen to this
that
really aspire to go into leadership so
i just want to ask you a couple of
questions on that and i think you
alluded to it straight away because i'm
sure you've helped people overcome some
of those challenges like i've
a sort of common phrase that i've heard
be chucked around in the industry is
that
a sort of billing man being a billing
manager is one of the hardest roles in
the industry
right but like you said actually sort of
looking back or now
when you then end up leading teams where
you was just in the leadership role
rather than
leading by example that's one of the
great positives you have when being in
the bidding manager but
what i always hear is is the sort of
management of the self-management of
time
always tends to like that's what i keep
hearing when i speak to billing managers
it's
how much time should i spend with my
team without the detriment of my own
performance
and i'm sure you've helped people with
this in your career so i guess if i ask
you
i don't know what sort of um
self-management systems or time
management
systems did you live by when you was
when you was a bidding manager that
really worked for you or you've helped
other people with does
anything come up for you on that yeah i
think
you have to work in a really green way
when you are a billing manager
and um so for me it was always about
your job is to get people to be able to
to do this job
well um without you know autonomously
and so where you will see i think a lot
of people really struggle with this
is they're not really setting their
people up
to do the job autonomously like they're
jumping in
and doing stuff for them whereas for me
it was
kind of a simple process of you know
breaking down you know what are all the
different elements and components of
this job
and um you know you train
people on air and when you train
don't just train one person train more
you know train train everyone even if
that means you're giving people
kind of a refresher it's it's training
people
it's them seeing you do it so you know
why would i ever be taking a job spec
for example
without having someone on my team listen
in if i know that i know how to take a
brilliant job
spec why am i going to do that by myself
and then um you know not using relay
unity for for training and then the same
thing right is
you know you've seen me do it and now
i'm going to support you and give you
feedback on yours and and really what
you
what you're doing as as time goes by is
your your check in the competency boxes
for these people so
over time there's there's sort of less
and less
um less and less support that you need
to give and
if you if you know you've trained
someone really well
then you can also use them as the role
model
and and you know as as uh support for
for kind of the broader team so i think
it's all about do it properly
with the first people that you on board
work really green and actually those
initial people
they'll be super competent too and that
that's how you that's how you grow a
team
effectively and you don't do it alone
okay so a few sort of couple of things
on
leadership that i'd love to ask you one
is obviously as you said you scaled um
this
this business to obviously around 500
people by the time that you left now
that involved
obviously multiple brands it wasn't then
just obviously the banking uh brand that
you
essentially earn your stripes and let's
say for a lack of a better phrase but
i i've gotten a question for you like
how how did you approach
leading teams that you'd never recruited
for what was that experience like
because i think people listen to this
are probably people that are
aspirational maybe in the leadership
may be open to taking head of direct
positions in other companies but
that may be in for a different sector so
i think it's quite interesting
channeling i've had a couple of people
ask me about it to ask people on on this
show so what's been your experience in
leading team that you never actually
recruited in yourself of interest
i mean that's the difference between
having a big business right is that if
you want to have a big business
then i mean it's ludicrous to think that
you are going to have recruited in
in every single vessel also
you have to have processes
and structures and structures to be able
to
uh apply a really good strategy
and um and structures around execution
and if you've got if you know how to
evaluate
is this a good market same set of
questions right it's the same set of
questions
that you're going to apply to any market
to sort of understand
is this a good market what's the
dynamics of that market is it candidate
driven is it job driven
what's this what's the client what
should the client strategy
look like what should the candidate
strategy look like all those
different things there that's about
having having the right
uh processes and the right questions and
so you don't need to know
a business intimately you just need to
know what you need to to know in order
to be able to
to to make smart decisions yeah so
yeah yeah so i guess what you're saying
there is focus on those things that you
have experience in rather than
trying to sort of be perceived as the
expert in
that vertical or whatever double down on
the things that have
yeah will show up in the verticals and
markets that you have
managed or recruited in the past and
then yeah okay
i mean yeah i mean at a point at that
stage
your expertise is leading
recruitment businesses to growth and
so the point isn't actually about
how detailed your market knowledges of
each
of those different verticals i mean when
you look at
uh some some pretty senior
c-level executives within some of the
large recruitment companies
including the current ceo of s3 no
recruitment experience at all
it came from completely different
industries so the further that you go up
the chain
actually it's it's your leadership
expertise
it's your strategic thinking is your
approach to risk management
is your ability to manage a p l it's
you know your uh people strategy those
are the things that become
important and the the the
the ins and outs of you know a
recruitment market
are less important and i appreciate this
iterative right depends where you're at
but if people can get their head in the
game of
you know i need to start to add value
to the recruitment process without
intimately knowing these markets if i
want to
to continue to to kind of rise up the
you know it through through the ranks
then i think that's that's a good
a good way to start thinking to to get
you to that point
yeah got it really really well put um i
have to ask you this because you've been
involved in leading so many people and i
think
it's something that a lot of managers
and leaders think about in recruitment
but what
what's what's been your journey in like
getting the best out of your
teams like when i say to you you know
how like how have you got the best out
of your teams i know
there will be nuances to particular
individuals and teams but
what what comes up for you they're like
what typically
has sort of really helped you get the
best out of your teams out of interest
yeah i think leading with empathy is
really important
sometimes can feel a little bit cliche
but i think it is important
and leading with empathy it doesn't mean
that you don't have
high standards it doesn't mean that you
don't hold people accountable
i'm big on accountability accountability
for myself and accountability for my
teams
and we've always had very high standards
but
if those things are in place then the
way that you lead
motivate empower coach so i'd lean
heavily
on on coaching uh to get the best out of
people
but you know those things that's really
kind of the
the method to get to that sort of
destination
and so i think kind of treating people
with um
treating people with respect and um
and kind of supporting them meeting them
where they are is
is really important and giving
really really clear expectations so
that's not one to be overlooked
when i support other leaders
you know and and they're struggling to
get the best out of others
when i really do a bit of a deep dive
there's just disconnect and expectations
so you know the man who wants one thing
um but the other that you know the the
employee just
isn't isn't clear right there's just
there's not that
that there's not crystal clear clarity
of expectations
and so that's something for me is that i
never
would have people in my team not know
what i
expected of them because that's where
you you know everything
flows back from from that really yeah
that's a really good point i'd love to
know
if you were to if we were to take a
random recruitment business
and and we were to say to the
consultants
of a 5 to 15 person team like
do you know exactly what you need to do
this month that
your sort of team or leadership requires
of you or expects from you
how many people would be able to answer
that in a really crystal
clear way i need to pull do this like
that'll be really interesting actually i
think that's a really
very interesting every very interesting
exercise and i think that percentage
would be
extremely low yeah yeah yeah i think
that'd be really interesting so
what i wanted to ask you next then is
what
what's been your journey like
what's been your journey with imposter
syndrome
because i feel like you've you went on
this journey and i
you struck me as someone that really
took in your stride you have high
standards you've
continued to work on yourself you don't
struggle with someone that wasn't
willing to ask for help like i don't
know what's been your journey in
overcoming or having or even
experiencing imposter syndrome as you
so continue to lead more people and
we're doing more things that
a lot more first i don't know what's
been your journey with that
i think anyone who says that they
don't have impostor syndrome is either a
liar
or they're not sitting at different
tables
because the reality is for me imposter
syndrome
definitely shows up when you do those
firsts as you said
so the more ambitious you are the more
you put
yourself in situations where you're in
different rooms
and you're you're sitting at different
tables and of course you have those
moments where you're like oh
i shouldn't be here and i've had those
moments before
actually over the last few years i've
had quite a
uh quite a transformative journey with
imposter syndrome
where i realized that
you know you can only be an imposter if
you're trying to show up as someone
other than yourself
and showing up authentically as me
and really leaning into what i bring to
the table
and who i am um has has really meant
for me that that's kind of that's sort
of gone away
because i'm not trying i'm not trying to
anticipate what people need from me i'm
not trying to anticipate
like who i should be and just you know
trying to gloss over that extra kind of
ten percent and just
show up authentically and quite
fearlessly as me
and i think it translates better as well
like people
people buy into authenticity
no yeah i really like the way that you
put that and i guess part of that then
which i'll be interested to hear your
sort of journey with par for you to
really understand
how to authentically lean into you being
you and what you bring to the table
requires definitely a good sense of
self-awareness
and understanding what you like what's
been your journey with sort of
cultivating self-awareness and
understanding what does what value do i
bring in this
in this boardroom and this context and
yeah what's been your journey of
cultivating self-awareness out of
interest
i'm going to be honest with you i
actually think imposter syndrome
is um probably linked with high
self-awareness
so it's not people
syndrome who are not self-aware um when
you've got impostor syndrome
uh it's because you're actually very
aware of
where you are and what your experience
is and you think quite critically about
yourself
the people that are completely oblivious
and have a total different
self-perception
they don't have imposter syndrome
they're the people that sit in the rooms
and
kind of make a bit of an idiot of
themselves right because they
think they're much bet better than they
are and and their ego comes through
so um yeah like for me i'm i'm i've
always been incredibly self-aware
um it's more actually about um
i think for a lot of people who are
trying to conquer this is about
conquering perfectionism conquering
being too self-critical on themselves
like those
those are the things that you need to
focus in on
yeah no interesting so i feel like we've
um
this has been quite positive so far so
obviously as we know
recruitment comes with highs and lows
it's like talk to me about
if when i say to you what was like the
sort of toughest part of that journey in
america and work for the s free group
like what what comes up for you and like
what helped you work through it
um yeah i mean i'll be honest with you
i've had
a really great i had a great experience
at s3
and i'm quite resilient but um
you know i moved to chicago in 2011
and set up that that region for s3
and that there was a little bit of that
that was it was it was very
under resourced and you know there
wasn't a ton of support and
and i think the company's perspective
where you did it before for as you do it
again
they kind of would divide the diver in a
lot of resources to other areas
and i sort of felt a little bit like you
know
because i can do it doesn't mean that
you shouldn't support me better
and there was something to be said
for you know i just i felt like i'd done
this already in new york
and then start in all over again and you
definitely have to check
your energy level force you know
starting something new and starting
something new again because
it is there's only so many times i think
that we can
go through that same journey and um
and so fortunately the the midwest
became
you know a hugely profitable uh region
for s3 but it was definitely
tough kind of start in starting again
and
not working with very much yeah okay
fair enough
so what um so i'm i'm really
excited to go through the sort of early
stages of you starting your own
recruitment business
but i guess just a couple of things that
could translate to also
part of your mission with your own
business but i have i have to obviously
speak to you about this and that's sort
of women in recruitment right
so i think from what i can see from your
brand you do a really
great job of um talking about
this as part of your brand so
then why don't i share with you just
some of the things that i've sort of
learned from sitting down with people
like yourself so what
what i've come to find is that
when i speak to um women in recruitment
it seems like and i think hopefully i
feel like this this could have really
changed and shifted over the last sort
of year or so but
i've felt that when i speak to women who
have ended up in the leadership position
they've found it really difficult to get
there
because along the way they would have
had to make some really difficult
decisions on the crossroads of starting
a family and
then that sort of pegging them back with
their career and finding it back hard to
get to the
sort of senior position where they work
really hard to so that seems to be a
real
common challenge for women which i feel
like could potentially impact
more women in leadership and senior
positions i'd like to think
the sort of flexibility and remoteness
that's come with the past sort of 18
months or so
could hopefully really impact that and
then the other part
is then i think which you spoke really
well about whenever i've spoken to
um women in recruitment as well one of
the common things that i feel women talk
more about than
um i think men is is that sort of um
navigating with imposter syndrome and
maybe not being as willing to put their
hand up for that promotion or think that
they're deserving of that promotion
and whereas men probably still have
those same feelings but
mourning to put their hand up yeah i'll
do that even though they're not the
finished article or whatever
so i guess i don't know what what's been
like you're obviously a great story this
but a lot of people
sort of in their own recruitment
business don't have female role models
that they can look up to and go wow
jeanette's achieved this in my business
that's
sort of someone that i'd really like to
aspire to they actually
have to become that rom that be driven
by becoming that role model themselves
so i don't know what how i don't know
how do you feel about sort of
women in leadership and senior positions
in recruitment is that something that
is going in the right direction like
what more work do you think we have to
do there and what are some of the
reasons why
um women are probably um un
underrepresented
at that level yeah i think there's a lot
um
that you kind of say there uh
you know first of all clearly there is a
lot of work to be done
i mean we just saw a set of statistics
recently
um you know for kind of u.s staffing
firms and
the number of women in in kind of senior
executive roles was
uh was quite pitiful right so even when
we're talking about making progress
yeah we're making steps forward but the
numbers still don't
look very good so so yes there's
there's a lot of work that needs to be
done um
yes there are still barriers in place
for women who
want to have a family and often that's
just about
how they're perceived and how their
commitments perceived and
people taking opportunities away from
them because they're assuming
rather than then can ask him so there's
there's all of those things
uh you know you talk about men
um you know are they gonna ask for
promotions i mean when
even something as simple as pay rises
men ask four times
as often as women so you know it stands
to reason if you ask more then you get
more
and i think exactly the same thing
applies to to kind of promotions and
and you know some some sort of
gender bias and gender
specific behaviors kind of come in where
women are far more likely to wait to be
recognized or if they get told to
you know we're going to work on this
promotion for the next 12 months and
they'll sit and they'll diligently work
on it whereas
i mean i've experienced this myself
where you know men
are lobbying for exceptions kind of left
right and center
and if you don't if the organization
itself
doesn't hold firm to those same
standards that's where this
becomes really difficult right is is
that
if you're in a company that says you
know we don't make any exceptions
ever then it's a level playing field but
if
that's not the case this culture of
exceptions
really sets sets women
up in particular i think for failure
because
we don't tend to generally not ask for
exceptions and
and we don't really do the whole
self-promotion thing
and so i think a few different things
to kind of come about one i think
there's a lot more
visibility and discussion around this
now which is is definitely helping
to to shine a light on on this
and is is actually kind of helping women
to
to navigate and self-manage different
it's also helping leaders and
and managers to kind of do the same
thing too is is to kind of
be be so much more aware and
and in turn that means that there's more
people are trying to be more equitable
in how they're managing men and
women um but then
you know a a right alongside that
and you know you've you've also
you kind of mentioned this mentoring and
kind of role models
i think if if women can understand
it's a big world out there and it took
me a while to realize this too
you don't just have to look for role
models in your own organization
there's tons of places that you can get
mentors and it doesn't always have to be
a recruitment mentor
you know one of my early mentors was
someone in a completely different field
and that was great because i got totally
different perspective
so i think just really surrounding
yourself
with positive role models uh you know
irrespective of the industry can also
really help shape your thinking and your
own development
yeah i love that so obviously this is
part of the
the puzzle but like obviously let's sort
of talk about
obviously this is a big part of your
mission with your own recruitment
business now isn't it and helping
organizations
and with diversity excellent inclusion
so i guess
so again giving you context of what i've
sort of
sort of experienced from speaking to
recruiters
this is what seems to be happening
although there are i feel like more and
more recruiters that have been really
proactive
but the experience that i seem to get
from recruiters
is when it comes to diversity is that
then they're not invited to the table
with their clients
on the actual topic of how can um
our business and employ a more diverse
talent
and where recruiters are then sort of
experiencing
um the diversity pieces their clients
are going we now need to
we need to start seeing diverse short
lists and diverse candidates
and and because they've been nowhere
near the conversation or even been
invited to the table because they've
never brought this conversation up or
topic a conversation up
recruiters then turn around and go and
how the hell do i do that
how do i start attracting and
communicating and building relationships
with
underrepresented um uh talent so
i guess like from your sort of journey
and
like where where can recruiters start
with their diversity journey like i'm
sure you will get this asked a lot
but like where like i'm i'm sure a lot
of people listen to this
i personally feel like a lot of people
generally do actually have the right
intention
yeah but i actually don't know where to
start and so we're also quite worried
about
standing on the wrong eggshells and
asking i don't know there's
there's a lot of things but i feel like
a lot of people don't know where to
start yeah i guess where would you
encourage people to start if
if their intentions there which is
probably one of the most important
things that they're in
their intent is the right thing rather
than just coming from a place of being a
tick box exercise and
just doing it to make one person happy
yeah well listen i would go back to what
i said at the beginning of this
conversation right we're there to solve
problems for our clients so
if if people say i i'm not invited to
that conversation
well why should you be right um you
are there to solve your client's problem
and so if you're engaging problem with
your client from the very beginning
you'll be asking them questions right so
from a talent perspective what are the
top three priorities for you what's
most important for you if you're having
those kind of conversations and right up
at the gate the client's going to be
saying you know
diversity equity inclusion right because
that is
that's that's the common challenge right
now and then you can have a conversation
with
with clients and actually come up with
with kind of a solution
together so the first thing i would say
is if people are finding themselves on
the back end
of that conversation then you're
probably not doing a good enough job
in um in in really kind of finding out
what's important to your clients
early on in the process and then
secondly
you know if a client does say this is my
priority
you're not you know as recruiters we're
not sort of
there as order takers right so if ever
you find yourself
in a situation where it's just kind of a
shopping list like
go away bring me that then again
something's kind of gone wrong
so if you're in a space that you really
understand you should be able to tell
the client what the demographic
is like you should be able to come up
with solutions
together um to to kind of support that
and it might be
that you shift in the conversation with
a client you're saying listen i can help
you find diverse talent
but that means that we're taking away
the speed element right which is
i'm completely fine with but we we need
to
to you know you you want a client to
work with you exclusively right because
going away and finding a diverse slate
of candidates
that takes more time that's not about
just going into your database it's
exactly what you said you
you kind of cultivate in relationships
you go in that kind of extra mile
and so the the sort of conversation
and and the the tone of how that search
is
is going to operate needs to be very
different yeah
okay and then obviously as we come to
the end here
talk to us about obviously yeah like a
huge huge step in starting your own
recruitment business
worked for one organization as you said
for as we've discussed for 15 years so
i'm sure you obviously possessed a lot
of confidence that you could do it but
at the same time it's again
stepping into that unknown like how how
has it been so far obviously you started
that journey in
april this year so how uh how has it
been so far
yeah it's early days so i i started um
harper and gray
very purpose lad so you know the idea
really being
able to address um talent
while putting diversity in inclusion
first and kind of solving for that in a
more holistic way
so supporting clients with diverse
slates of candidates when it comes to
hiring
helping them to develop equitable hiring
processes
and and then actually also performance
and executive coaching for their
leadership teams who
need to lead in a more in kind of
inclusive and
and kind of empowering way so sort of
those
that that kind of end to end is really
um looking at different ways through the
the sort of talent chain and the talent
process
and to to be able to solve for diversity
equity and inclusion
so i feel you know very passionate about
it's a
topic and and an area that i feel i've
got
a lot of kind of expertise in now and
really being able to put my
uh experience all of my recruitment
experience kind of
into something that feels very
mission-led uh
you know feels great but it's been it's
been four weeks
it's been crazy busy i've already signed
up my first client
and you know ton of uh you know ton of
interest and a ton of support for the
the admission of the of the brand so
i'm i'm excited to build something that
also feels quite scalable
to solve a very very large
problem and um and
yeah so so so far so good and i'm sure
that you know ask me in another six
months
you know there'll be a whole host of uh
of other kind of emotions
but um you know i i'm not new to
building a business i'm new to building
my own business
but i think there's some some benefit to
to having done this for an organization
because i i know
that it's it takes time and i i've got
i've got patience and um and kind of got
the t-shirt i think for this
now i'm really excited to to see it see
it grow from
afar so before we finish i've just got a
couple of
sort of quickfire questions to ask you
um
before i but before i do that just very
quickly um
i'd be silly not to ask you this but as
we come to the end here obviously you've
worked in the
the american market for some time now
like what's what's your sort of overall
feeling towards the american market i
mean i'm definitely speaking to more and
more
uk-based recruitment businesses that are
continuing now with their plans to get
into the us like i don't know what's
the sort of overall perspective of the
u.s recruitment market
is there still plenty of room for uk
basically
like really yeah there's plenty room
yeah okay so feeling positive yes
definitely yeah
nice so last couple of questions so the
last couple of questions i have for you
the first one
is if if you could change the industry
what would you improve i'd change
people's approach
to um to to
clients and and particularly to
candidates i i think
it's a human is it's a business that is
so heavily reliant upon human connection
and i don't always think that there is
an appropriate level of
of kind of respect and empathy for
um the fact that
changing jobs can sometimes be one of
the biggest
decisions that a person will make and
and i think
that there's there's a lot more room for
empathy
and and and a better experience for
people
sure and next one so
what book have you read that's had the
biggest impact on you do you think it
could be if you don't read
maybe audible podcast but what
have you sort of consumed or read or
whatever that's had a real impact on you
think
um no i do i look i i really enjoy
reading and
there's a couple actually that i've read
recently
and so reboot is one of them and
um dare to lead brene brown is uh
is the other one nice okay
it's a bit of a less serious one this
one before we finish so what
what did you spend your first biggest
commission paycheck on
i think paying off all my credit card
debt
really lovely awesome
final final question jeanette and that's
what what's the ultimate goal for your
recruitment career
my ultimate goal is to build a business
and a brand
that i feel really proud of and that is
actually making a real
demonstrable difference in the world
amazing
you know it's been an absolute pleasure
thank you so much thank you i'm excited
to see where your business goes thank
you
thank you